internets okay one forehead rondell do
you stand by your assertion that we're a
nation of wussies what can we do to man
up well again I think it's mostly about
leadership we need leaders we're gonna
tell em come on that's a wussy answer
right no that is a what's the answer I
swear to god you because you think if we
had a great leader the character of the
American people would suddenly change I
think it takes more than a great leader
I think we all have to start telling
people the truth and if we do that it'll
be easier for people to make tough
difficult decisions and you know it's a
way of life but it starts from the top
if we shy away from doing anything risky
at the top why should our people write
politicians just have to not care so
much about keeping their job absolutely
it's not that great a job yeah or maybe
it is maybe it's just such a Guttman it
must be a great job that must be it they
just you know McCain will be there at
least 110 they do not want to be that
kind of politician and then he just
utterly reversed himself you know in the
last few years but he who used to be
that way okay should politicians have to
take a test to prove that they are
actually smart enough to govern
good luck with that one well the fact
that Michele Bachmann is on the
Intelligence Committee is the is the
most oxymoronic the thing that we could
possibly have in our society you know
she yes she is it's pretty darn scary
yeah where would where should we draw
the line in terms of getting involved
with unrest in dictator run Middle
Eastern countries oh I don't know we've
got three going I think we could do for
the third war is the job but you know
the thing is there's there's an
undeclared war that's going on all
throughout the Horn of Africa and and in
Oman and in Yemen and the targeted
killing campaign we were talking about
earlier I mean that's that's been a war
that's been brewing from 2002 on when
Bush did a drone attack in Yemen and
killed six people including a US citizen
the world is a battlefield that's a
doctrine that was developed by the neo
cons and doubled down on by Obama do you
think America would be better off with a
parliamentary system of government why
Canada has I do actually I mean I love
our system the government in general but
you know Thomas Jefferson himself said
you really have to you look at this
every twenty years and we have come on
we have a system that is just paralyzed
and it seems like if you have a system
where you can vote out the leader
without the Party as a parliamentary
system can right I mean you can have a
no-confidence vote I mean couldn't we I
think we could retain some of the checks
and balances that make our system great
and also have that from as you don't get
Barack Obama though I used to cover
European politics and they have the same
six people leading the party decade
after decade yeah whereas our party
allows people to rise from nowhere and
take over a party so I but only two
parties it just seems a right in London
it's in England it's the same thing you
cannot get any new blood you know it
really takes decades to get any new
blood I think our structure is okay I
think some of the rules we put in suck
so for example 41 senators representing
17 percent of the American people can
stop something from coming into law that
rule ought to go and another go tomorrow
yes Mara right
in Italy in Italy you actually have
Silvio Berlusconi's mistresses have to
be elected that's where he led his bunga
bunga right that's why he doesn't want
to bomb them how is the independence of
the US judiciary really secured when the
appointment process is so political and
lowered judges actively campaigned for
office this is something the world
thinks is insane and I agree with them
that we have judges who have to run for
office this is supposed to be the one
branch of government you know that is
not subject to the mob and the masses
and the voting and we don't do it
certainly trees barn the reason they
will fail that civics test you know it's
just too many elections too many layers
too complicated I think it is in fact
extremely difficult to understand the
American civics system right and of
course when you too much judges
that's when people that's when the real
bloodthirsty Hillbillies come out of the
woodwork because that's the guy who
passes down the laws and punishes people
and we don't throw people in prison and
that's why we have don't we have more
people per capita in prison than any
other country in the world somehow were
the best people in the world but we put
the most in prison seems crazy all right
how much clearer could Obama possibly be
about our objectives in Libya he spelled
it out for us
pretty much in ice I asked that question
fool asking questions all right we're
done into questions we're done Thank You
panel Thank You audience we will see you
next week
[Applause]